for as far back as we can trace our
existence humans have been fascinated
with death and resurrection
nearly every religion in the world has
some interpretation of them and from our
earliest myths to the latest cinematic
blockbusters the dead
keep coming back but is resurrection
really possible and what is the actual
difference between a living creature and
a dead body anyway to understand what
death is we need to understand what life
is
one ancient theory was an idea called
vitalism which claimed that living
things were unique because they were
filled with a special substance or
energy that was the essence of life
whether it was called Chi life blood or
humors the belief in such an essence was
common throughout the world and still
persists in the stories of creatures who
can somehow drain life from others or
some form of magical sources that can
replenish it vitalism began to fade in
the Western world following the
Scientific Revolution in the 17th
century Rene Descartes advanced the
notion that the human body was
essentially no different from any other
machine brought to life by a divinely
created soul located in the brains
pineal gland and in 1907 dr. Duncan
MacDougall even claimed that the soul
had mass weighing patients immediately
before and after death in an attempt to
prove it though his experiments were
discredited much like the rest of
vitalism traces of his theory still come
up in popular culture but where do all
these discredited theories leave us what
we now know is that life is not
contained in some magical substance or
spark but within the ongoing biological
processes themselves and to understand
these processes we need to zoom down to
the level of our individual cells inside
each of these cells chemical reactions
are constantly occurring powered by the
glucose and oxygen that our bodies
convert into the energy carrying
molecule known as ATP cells use this
energy for every
from repair to growth to reproduction
not only does it take a lot of energy to
make the necessary molecules but it
takes even more to get them where they
need to be the universal phenomenon of
entropy means that molecules will tend
towards diffusing randomly moving from
areas of high concentration to low
concentration or even breaking apart
into smaller molecules and atoms so
cells must constantly keep entropy in
check by using energy to maintain their
molecules in the very complicated
formations necessary for biological
functions to occur the breaking down of
these arrangements when the entire cell
succumbs to entropy is what eventually
results in death this is the reason that
organisms can't be simply sparked back
to life once they've already died we can
pump air into someone's lungs but it
won't do much good if the many other
processes involved in the respiratory
cycle are no longer functioning
similarly the electric shock from a
defibrillator doesn't jumpstart an
inanimate heart but resynchronize --is
the muscle cells in an abnormally
beating heart
so they regain their normal rhythm this
can prevent a person from dying but it
won't raise a dead body or a monster
sewn together from dead bodies so it
would seem that all our various medical
miracles can delay or prevent death but
not reverse it but that's not as simple
as it sounds because constant
advancements in technology and medicine
have resulted in diagnosis such as coma
describing potentially reversible
conditions under which people would have
previously been considered dead in the
future the point of no return may be
pushed even further some animals are
known to extend their lifespans or
survive extreme conditions by slowing
down their biological processes to the
point where they are virtually paused
and research into cryonics hopes to
achieve the same by freezing dying
people and reviving them later when
newer technology is able to help them
see if the cells are frozen there's very
little molecular movement and diffusion
practically stopped
even if all of a person's cellular
processes had already broken down this
could still conceivably be reversed by a
swarm of nanobots moving all the
molecules back to their proper positions
and injecting all of the cells with ATP
at the same time presumably causing the
body to simply pick up where it left off
so if we think of life not as some
magical spark but a state of incredibly
complex self-perpetuating organization
death is just the process of increasing
entropy that destroys this fragile
balance and the point at which someone
is completely dead turns out not to be a
fixed constant but simply a matter of
how much of this entropy we're currently
capable of reversing
Oh